c'est un sujet qui est extrêmement
intéressant aujourd'hui je vous parle
d'un des derniers smartphones de rim me
peut-être le dernier smartphone de rim
mis à l'heure à laquelle sont cette
vidéo c'est celui là c'est le readme x50
pro professionnels et surtout un modèle
5g et un modèle qui est extrêmement
intéressant de par son positionnement
je vais tout vous expliquer je vais tous
vous détailler pour moi ça c'est le
smartphone du compromis
il n'est pas parfait il est assez
imparfait mais par contre les choix qui
ont été faits par remy derrière qui sont
très bons qui me sens en tout cas être
très juste et qui leur permettent
surtout de proposer un smartphone un
tarif très intéressant avec ce qu'il
faut juste ce qu'il faut pour être
extrêmement compétitif parce que la
question à se poser c'est qu'est ce
qu'on veut quand on cherche un nouveau
smartphone le piège c'est tombé dans les
spécifications techniques c'est de lire
une fiche technique
la plupart du temps c'est pas vraiment
un contrat correspond ça me permet
d'avoir des idées pas se dire tiens six
numéros et plus haut c'est mieux ça sert
d'être mieux que ça mais dans l'absolu
on a un peu de mal à voir un peu de
visibilité mais la réalité c'est prendre
le problème à l'envers c'est de
réfléchir par rapport à vous vos besoins
vos usages qu'est ce que vous faites de
votre smartphone et bien souvent il ya
quelques gros c'est ce qui ressort et
c'est vraiment les points les plus
importants et c'est là dessus en tout
cas que renmin sans avoir fait un gros
focus le premier point c'est le multi
mais dia et salle multimédia ça veut
dire beaucoup de choses ça veut dire le
gaming vod on va dire ça comme ça
youtube netflix ça veut dire aussi tout
ce qui va être réseaux sociaux instagram
twitter facebook
tik tok et tout ce que vous voulez en
gros si vous avez vraiment un triptyque
de ce qu'on va retrouver au niveau du
multimédia et qu'est ce qui vous permet
d'avoir une bonne expérience multimédia
et bien ça va être d'avoir un bon écran
il faut derrière a bien évidemment un
audio de qualité notamment pour tout ce
qui va être vod et gaming et bien
évidemment pour la grosse partie gaming
il vous faut derrière beaucoup de
performances sans quoi vous aurez un
problème est là tissu reconnaître que
remy a vraiment très bien travaillé on
vous proposons un combo qui fonctionne
merveilleusement bien
peut-être un des meilleurs combos pour
vous sortir un des smartphones les plus
performants en tout cas à l'heure à
laquelle je fais cette vidéo pour moi le
smartphone le plus performant pour
réussir sarr il mit a choisi juste le
meilleur que vous avez si un écran de
6,44 pouces c'est un écran samsung une
dalle super amoled
on connaît le travail de samsung au
niveau des dalles et une fois de plus
croyez moi si vous avez quelque chose
qui marche vraiment bien vous avez une
résolution de 2400 pixels par 1080
pixels qui occupent 92% de la face avant
on pourra venir regretter si vous n'ayez
pas de bords incurvés mais une fois de
plus on est vraiment dans le compromis
un smartphone avec un taux de
rafraîchissement de 90 ans
moi ce que je vous conseille quand même
7 vous mettre ici en sélection
automatique
remy où il va bien choisir de switcher
soit 90 hertz soit entre 61 et vous
allez économiser davantage de batterie
un écran extrêmement lumineux qui peut
aller jusqu'à 100 dit vous verrez très
très bien en extérieur une gamme de
couleurs 100% dci p3 en écran certifié
lutter contre la lumière bleue est
certifié hdr dispute et puisqu'on est
dans le compromis
il n'est pas complètement parfait on est
sur un smartphone qui coûte je voulais
tout de suite un petit peu moins de 600
euros 599 1,90 dans la configuration 8
gigas de ram 128 go de stockage
il ya d'autres conflits que joe détails
en fait plus tard dans la vidéo une fois
de plus dans le compromis passe car
moins de 600 euros il a fallu faire des
choix ici
rigby nous a pas mis d'écran noeuds 120
hertz pour avoir des écrans de 120 hertz
va falloir débourser un peu plus
d'argent et c'est ça qui est intéressant
c'est le curseur ou est-ce que remy a
mis son curseur puisque si vous regardez
vous voyez que le tarif à un petit peu
moins 600 euros on est dans le tarif ou
retrouver habituellement du one plus one
+ a fait une montée en gamme coûte
aujourd'hui un peu plus cher par contre
là vous aurez un tour affranchissement
de sangatte et non pas 80 des herbes et
si vous voulez encore mieux aller
toujours plus haut et bien vous rajoutez
vous voyez que chez omis avec notamment
son milices pro est quasiment à 1000
euros il ya donc des smartphones à tous
les prix et c'est là-dessus qui est venu
se positionner et demi au juste prix
vous proposer le smartphone avec
l'essentiel est une fois de plus le bon
compromis
la partie audio non plus n'est pas en
reste avec des haut-parleurs stéréo pour
une expérience multimédia maximiser dans
tous ses smartphones haut de gamme très
haut de gamme la prise jack a disparu r
il n'y a fait le choix bien évidemment
aussi de l'enlever tout simplement parce
qu'ils considèrent que des personnes qui
vont avoir les moyens d'acheter un
smartphone haut de gamme auront
potentiellement les moyens de s'acheter
un casque sans fil le choix a été fait
là dessus de mètres du bluetooth 5
points avec tous les codecs qui vont
bien sbc a assez répété x a pété xhd
ldlc
personnellement je trouve que
l'expérience multimédia est plutôt bonne
déjà vous avez beaucoup de puissance
c'est très dur de rentrer comme ça et
j'en conviens parfaitement mais ce que
je peux vous assurer c'est que vous avez
un stade qui est assez large pour
trouver quand même son rond assez grave
dans la capacité de ce que peut
développer un haut parleur de
smartphones bien évidemment il n'a pas
avoir tendance à tordre lorsque vous
allez monter le niveau temps je veux
dire saturé vous retrouvez une belle
spatialisation entre les hauts parleurs
qui se retrouvent sur un côté là et le
haut parleur qui les trouvent ici alors
on n'a pas la même direct sur du son
mais néanmoins lorsque vous allez vous
regarder une série jouer vous avez comme
son expérience de spatialisation ça
marche bien et une fois de plus c'est le
compromis on ne peut pas tout avoir
mais là où ça devient extrêmement
bluffant est très intéressant c'est au
niveau de la performance puisque ce
smartphone là c'est une bête de
compétition en termes de puissance tu
sais pas si vous en souvenez il ya
quelques vidéos je vous parlais du chiot
me d'une milice pro qui était le
smartphone qui avait le meilleur
classement se rend tous qui était le
smartphone le plus performant grâce à un
combo gagnant l cyril mis à prix la même
recette et a mis la barre encore plus
haute snapdragon 865 vous avez de la ram
c'est de la lp dvr 5 et le stockage
c'est lui fs 3.0 et ce congo la lui
permet d'obtenir le score de 597 1963
sur en tout je sais là je me perds un
peu dans les travers des spect ou non
des spect pour des specs
en gros ce qu'il faut comprendre c'est
que vous avez le processeur de
smartphone le plus puissant vous avez la
technologie drame la plus puissante et
vous avez la technologie de stockage de
lecture et d'écriture la plus puissante
vous avez un truc qui marche
parfaitement bien et qui voulut classe
et c'est ça qui est assez incroyable ont
toute première position devant le chien
au mileu milices pro qui jusqu'à il ya
très peu de temps et elle nomme beroy
nous n'avons qu'à smartphones qui est
très très très très performant et qui
pour le gaming va aller très loin pour
faire tourner tout ce que vous voulez
dessus sans aucun problème on a une
machine qui est très bien pour l'instant
mais qui aussi bien pour l'avenir
puisque si vous prenez un smartphone
comme celui là en tout cas si vous
prenez ce smartphone là eh bien vous
savez que dans un an vous allez voir un
smartphone qui sera encore actuel qui
aura été dépassé par le processeur qui
arrivera en fin d'année mais qui restera
quand même très actuel et ça pendant un
petit moment d'autant plus que là dessus
vous avez de la 5g donc cette petite
machine là elle est très performante
aujourd'hui elle le sera encore l'année
prochaine et elle
cordes pas mauvaise dans deux ans quand
vous voyez pour un peu moins de 100
euros satar est en plus on est sur un
smartphone qui ne chauffe pas puisque la
5g dégage toujours plus de chaleur ici
vous avez le viper colline je vous le
fais à l'anglais ce qui va venir
dissiper l'acheteur de smartphones dont
bien évidemment pour la 5g ça va
diffuser la chaleur mais lorsque vous
allez jouer à des grandes parties de
jeux et bien de la même manière vous
n'allez pas voir un smartphone qui va
surchauffée et ça s'est vraiment bien
puisqu'on attend la question du
compromis qu'il ya un choix qui a été
fait et qui n'est pas un compromis
c'est le choix de l'autonomie on a ici
une batterie de 4200 millions père alors
c'est quelque chose d'assez standard par
contre un truc est vraiment bien ce
qu'ils vous ont sorti salle le blog de
charges super d'arte ça c'est très
grosse et très épais c'est bien plus
épais que vos smartphones mais surtout
ça vous permet de le recharger de 0 à
100 % seulement 35 minutes avec un
chargeur 65 watts et croyez moi c'est
extrêmement efficace mais que brûler
dans le compromis on ne peut pas tout
avoir
on n'a pas ici de charge sans fil bien
que vous ayez un dos en verre qui est
d'ailleurs plutôt pas mal comme ça avec
un verre dépoli et bien vous n'avez pas
de recharge sans fil vous n'avez pas non
plus de recherche inversée c'est à dire
que vous ne pouvez pas venir charger un
autre smartphone grâce à votre
smartphone mais à 600 euros est ce que
c'est vraiment ce que vous allez venir
rechercher
est-ce que vous en avez l'utilité
peut-être de la recharge sans fil
d'ailleurs dites le moi en bas en
commentaire mais croyez-moi déjà avec ce
que vous avez là votre smartphone vous
pouvez le garder deux jours facilement
ces deux smartphones qui tourne sur
risle me why basé sur l'android 10 si
vous connaissez colorait ce ça pourra
vraiment venir vous rappeler que leurs
os puisque c'est vraiment la même base
on a ici un os qui est très complet qui
permet de paramétrer beaucoup de choses
un des points qui aussi les plus
intéressants c'est au niveau de la
photographie puisque ici vous voyez vous
avez quatre capteurs photos tout en haut
ici c'est un téléobjectif de 12
mégapixels tout bref 2.5 c'est un
équivalent 54 mm qui vous permet d'aller
jusqu'à un zoom numérique x 20 en
dessous vous avez un grand angle c'est
une caméra de 64 mégapixels couvre être
en coin 800 équivalents 26 mm qu'il
n'est absolument pas stabilisée vous
avez en dessous en ultra grand-angle de
8 mégapixels ouvre à f 2.3 les killers
de 15 7 mm s'il vous plaît avec un champ
de vision 219 degrés tandis qu'en
dessous vous avez un objectif avec un
capteur de 2 mégapixels qui ouvre à f
2.4 c'est du noir et blanc elle est là
pour le mode portrait pour les faits
bocquet est ici à l'avant vous avez un
double module photo avec une caméra
grand angle de 30 2 mégapixels qui ouvre
à f2
1 5 et 1 ultra grand-angle de 8
mégapixels et ouvre à f 2.2 avec un
champ de vision de 105 degrés et mais en
plus de ça vous avez de la macro grâce à
l' ultra grand-angle tu veux montrer les
résultats et des choses qui sont bien
sûr ce qu'ils sont un peu moins bien
mais une fois de plus on lit dans le
smartphone du compromis comme le reste
la partie photo est un gros compromis là
on est sur le capteur principal
on va ensuite passé sur l'ultra grand
temps il ya une différence de
colorimétrie on le voit tout de suite
c'est pas parfait mais ça fonctionne on
va se rapprocher ensuite avec un zoom x
2 on passe au x 5 salissent et des
chronos x 20 bien évidemment le rendu
n'est plus du tout qualitatif j'étais un
candidat du x 10 déjà on perd beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup en qualité capteur
principal m'a bien fait le point sur un
fleuve qui cherchait d'ailleurs à
switcher entre la macro est l'objectif
principal
moi je l'ait vraiment laissé sur
l'objectif principal il m'a flouter le
reste on voit bien ici ma fleur qui bien
des tours et on voit bien la petite
partie à côté ça marche très très bien
l' ultra grand-angle c'est moins beau
une gestion des hautes lumières et tout
de suite un peu moins bonne c'est pas
exceptionnel fois de sa marche c'est
qualitatif x 5 c'est pas trop mal mais
tout de suite c'est beaucoup plus brut
et il faut à 20 voiliers fut le résultat
est pas drôle du tout caméra principale
ultra-grand-angle x 2 x 5 et x 20 la
même chose ici caméra principale ça
fonctionne bien l'ultra grand temps
quand vous avez beaucoup lumière marche
radecki un peu moins de lumière c'est
moins terrible x 2 x 5 c'est moins bon
il faut avoir ça fonctionne pas du tout
on va chercher ensuite à passer sur
deûle un maquereau alors moi la macro je
suis pas emballé je trouve ça marche pas
trop mal dans certaines situations mais
là je trouve pas ça fout il faut vous
une distance de 3 cm et voyez bon et des
petits effets c'est rigolo on a beaucoup
de mal à trouver la bonne position
sans quoi c'est rapidement flou c'est
assez raté c'est très imprécis et dans
l'absolu c'est pas génial
la grosse difficulté c'est de trouver la
bonne distance sur quelques jolies
fleurs ça marchera ça a tendance quand
même à l'iss et à bruitées pour moi le
rendu là dessus il n'est pas du tout
qualitatif je pense que la macro c'est
plus un artifice pour ajouter une corde
de plus à son arc mais qui ne s'est
globalement a pas grand chose devant les
photos prises avec le bonne nuit en
faible luminosité
non pas que j'aime donald trump mer une
fois de plus pour moi c'est le petit
signe qu'il fait à tout le monde ça
représente bien tout ce que je pense de
ce monsieur le rendu est assez pâle pas
extraordinaire je l'essayé comme ça il a
eu du mal à faire le point et s'il n'y
avait absolument pas lumière
les volets fermés et voyez c'est pas
particulièrement qualitatif le mode
portrait fonctionne plutôt bien on a un
très bon du tout rage et faute d'être
derrière on a la grosse puissance de
calcul et pour marquer si on n'a pas de
lasers et bien résultat quand même très
très bon il a eu un tout petit peu de
mal ici c'est vraiment pas grand chose
la caméra de celle fille aussi fait la
sphère ce capteur principal ici là 30 2
mégapixels
c'est somme toute assez correcte et dès
que vous passez sont ultra grand-angle
il ya un petit effet c'est pas maps vous
permettra de faire des photos avec vous
et vos amis
il ya une différence de colorimétrie on
le voit tout de suite mais je trouve
néanmoins que sa tendance un petit peu
alice et s'est pas complètement dingue
mais ça fait le boulot vous voyez il
n'est pas parfait serait 1050 chromé il
y a tout ce qu'il faut pour venir vous
convaincre un peu moins de 600 euros
le capteur d'empreintes digitales
extrêmement réactif le dos ne prend
absolument aucune trace de doigt il est
protégé à l'avant grâce un verre corning
gorilla glass un qu il a du wifi 6 du
nfc pour google paie un gps double
fréquence mais par contre une fois de
plus il n'a pas tout il n'a par exemple
pas de certification ip il n'est donc
pas certifié résistant à l'eau et à la
poussière il va donc falloir savoir ce
que vous voulez si pour vol usage c'est
multimédia ce smartphone là est très
clairement fait pour vous la partie
photo est intéressante mais perfectible
néanmoins on est une fois de plus sur un
smartphone un peu moins de 600 euros et
d'ailleurs je dois tout les confier tous
les prix ici sur ma petite feuille je
voulais dit la version 8 gigas de ram
+128 giga de stockage coûte 599 euros 90
autant dire qu'à 10 centimes
on est à 600 euros 8 plus de 156 vous
êtes assis 169,90 et 12 oui puisqu'on
pouvait monter jusqu'à 12 giga de ram
pour avoir encore plus de fluidité 12
plus de 156 vous êtes à 749 euros 90 il
faut savoir qu'ici c'est un smartphone
qui est non extensible néanmoins ce
smartphone qui peut accueillir une
double carte sim voilà pour ce
smartphone moi je trouve intéressant
c'est une fois de plus comme je voulais
dit je voulais répété tout au long c'est
le smartphone du compromis a vous de me
dire vous maintenant ce que vous en
pensez en bas en commentaires ou
personnellement je suis assez convaincu
et pour voir que réunissent une marque
qui arrivait il ya très peu de temps que
j'ai testé plusieurs smartphones de rim
lustres que cette montée en gamme est
vraiment bien vraiment maîtrisé et je
vous invite à vous abonner et à rester
connectés si c'est pas déjà le cas
puisqu'on va tester un autre smartphone
de rémy dans quelques temps sur ce je
vous embrasse tout le monde beaucoup
d'amour et vous donne rendez vous dès
demain pour continuer de parler tech
aller à demain matin
[Musique]